a lot of apps and websites are updating
their Terms of Service I'm talking about
the terms that users must accept before
using an app yeah and now most people
just click agree without reading the
fine print and probably aren't aware of
what they've agreed to so as a public
service I'm doing this for you we're
gonna look at a few right now okay for
example these are real Terms of Service
for example these streaming music app
Pandora
when you click agree on Pandora you
agree to give that one ed Sheeran song a
try that's real the neighborhood watch
app next door if you click agree on next
door you agree not to tell your
neighbors that all their lost cats were
definitely eaten by coyotes that is true
that's true that is true that's true
the female-driven dating app Bumble when
you click agree on bumble all men agree
to politely wait for the women to make
the first move and then send the exact
same dick picks they use on gender
that's assuming that's true
last time that guy fights a parking
ticket still doesn't make sense tinder
when you click agree on tinder boom you
now have herpes you already have herpes
boom double herpes
yeah let's clap that sure Instagram if
you click agree on Instagram you agree
that 100 or more likes will make up for
a father who never told you that you
were pretty
and finally the gay dating app Grindr
if you click agree on Grindr you agree
to say who downloaded that what a
prankster when your wife glances at your
farm
I was mining a flip phone which makes no
sense for that joke no I'm a dick all
right
you